[음악]
네 안녕하세요 빌사남 있니다 제가
오늘은 방배동 신축 현장에 와 있는데
준공이 얼마 남지 않았어요이 건물은
부동산 전문가로 잘 알려진 빠숑 님이
신축 중인 그런 건물입니다 함지박
사거리 이면에 위치한 건물이고
내방역에서 도보 약 10분 정도
거리에 위치한 건물입니다 돼지는 약
한 50평 정도고 연면적은 101평
지하는 따로 없고 지상 5층 정도
규모의 그런 빌딩입니다 주차는 세
대가 가능하고 엘리베이터는 7인승 한
대가 설치되어 있습니다 그리고 외관
마감은 붉은색 빨간 벽돌로 마감을
했고요 그리고 골든 색상 알루미늄
시트를 설치해서 포인트를 좀
두었습니다 그리고 측면에는 붉은색
벽돌의 두께를 좀 조절을 해 가지고
좀 입체감이 있게 그렇게 설계를
하였습니다네 무친 고는 3M 정도고
전층 다 넷 난방기가 설치가 되어
있습니다 그리고 남녀 화장실이 좀
구분이 되어 있고 여기 같은 경우에는
임차인이 자유롭게 인테리어를 할 수
있도록 최소한의 마감으로 하였습니다
그리고 계단실은 천장을 제외하고
나머지는 타일로 마감을 하였습니다네
지금 저는 4층에 올랐는데요 어
4층에는 이렇게 넓은 테라스가 설치가
되어 있습니다 그래서 4층을
이용하시는 임차인 분이 쾌적하게
사용하기 좋은 그런 공간입니다 빠숑
님을 모셔서 간단하게 인터뷰를
해보도록 하겠습니다 안녕하세요
안녕하세요 간단하게 자기소개 좀
부탁드리겠습니다네 스마트튜브 부동산
조사연구소 김학열 수장이라고 합니다
bsn 그룹에 예 김선 대표하고 뭐
오랜 행이 됐고요 이번 스마트튜브
빌딩 프로젝트에 같이 함께 하게 돼서
저도 영광이 많이습니다 아 그 얼마
전에 이제 비계가 철거됐던 좀 혹시
느낀 점이 좀 어떨까요 확실히 비계가
있을 때는 이게 좀 아 들어가야
되잖아요 답답하고 그랬었는데 좀 낡은
허물을 벗고 새로 태어나는 뭐 그런
느낌이 들어서 제가 이나이 먹고
그렇게 신선한 느낌을 들어 가자
대학을 때 한번 느껴봤던 거 제대할
때 느껴봤던 거 그런 느낌 있잖
시원한 거 신선한 경험이었던 거
같습니다 생각했던 거만큼 이제 건물이
좀 나왔을까요 생각했던 거보다 더
좋게 보이는 부분도 있고 기대했던
거보다 훨씬 좋고요 역시 부동산은
현장이고 직접 봐야 되는 것들이고
사진으로 아무리 잘 찍어도 실제보다는
안 나올 것 같아요 튼 실제 와서
보시면 좋을 거 같고요 뭐 주소
공개해도 되잖아요 아어 예 주소
공개해야 되 예 광배동 794-1번지
예예 맞습니다 예 한번 구경 보셔도
좋을 거 같고 평가해 주세요 직접네
그래서 주소 공개해 드렸으니까 한번
와서 보시면 좋을 거 같고요네 그
혹시 건물 중에 좀 자랑하고 싶은
부분이 있을까요 제가 좀 이렇게
클래식한 걸 좋아하고 조금 이렇게
중후하고 예스러운 것들을 좋아하는데
그 와중에서도 좀 세련된 포인트들이
있어서 얼핏 보면은 그냥 단순하게
빨간 벽돌 옛날 집처럼 보이지만
포인트들이 다 있어요 금색의 철강
판도 있고 그리고 또 옥상 가면은 뷰
포인트가 있어 갖고 전망이 확 대는
넓게 보이는 그런 부분들도 있고요
볼일 수 있는 최대한 넓이를 뽑았기
때문에 아마 층 별로도 아마 활용도가
높을 것 같고 주차 대수도 보 수
공간 한대 더 세울 수 있을 것 같고
큰 틀에서 디자인적인 측면에서도 좀
포인트를 많이 살렸고요 그다음에
디테일하게 활용할 수 있는 공간들을
많이 만들었으니까 와서 평가해 주시면
좋을 것 같다 말씀을 드려보도록
하겠습니다 그 아마 보시는 분 중에
이게 신축을 고민하시는 분이 계실 것
같아요 혹시 그분들한테 해주고 싶은
되었을까요 이게 이제 솔직히 돈이
많이 들긴 해요 초기 투자금도 많이
들지만 대출의 힘을 좀 이용하신다고
하면은 도전해 보시기를 추천드리고요
솔직히 이제 2022년도 2023년도
같은 경우는 고금리 시장이기 때문에
제가 추천을 못 드렸는데 다행히
최근에 이제 금리가 지금 많이
내려오고 있고 5%대 금리는 거의
없는 거 같고 4%대 3%대
금리까지도 좀 이게 능력이 있으신
분들은 받을실 수 있을 거 같으니까
그 정도를 기본 금리로 어 대출을 좀
활용하실 수 있는 분들 같은 경우는요
작게라도 정말 진짜 꼬마 빌딩이라고
1층이라고 2층이라도 도전해 보시기를
좀 추천드리고요 아파트만 한 25년
하다가 이제 신축이라 하는 걸 처음
해 봤는데 아까 말씀드린 대로
아파트에서 느끼지 못했던 쾌감이 하는
것들이 있고 어 신선했고 그리고 아마
다음에도 전 또 또 할 것 같아요
바로 또 할 거 같고 지금도 계속
물건 검색을 하고 있는데 실제 부동산
투자를 좀 꾸준히 하고 싶으신 분들은
뭐 토지라는 상가라는 그게 다
결정체가 꼬마 빌등 이잖아요 그 저는
부동산 투자의 종합 예술 종합
분야라고 생각하고 있기 때문에
추천드리고 싶어요 아 말씀 잘
들었고요 마지막으로 혹시 하시고 싶은
말씀 있으실까요 지금 뭐 설계
부분부터 해서 뭐 시공 감리 부분까지
총체적으로 신경을 많이 써주신 bsn
김수 대표님 이하 모든 예
직원분들한테 어 감사를 드리 고요
마무리 잘돼서 인대 형태로 좀 많이
제공이 될 거 같은데 뭐 통들도
좋고요 아마 좀 오셔 갖고 필요하신
분들은 쓰시면 좋을 거 같고요 제가
생각보다 비싸지
않게 예예 아마 아마이 빌딩 같은
경우는 제가 계속 소개를 할 수밖에
없잖아요 스마트 튜브라고 하는 어이
어떻게 보면 건축주가 있기 때문에
법인 건물이기 때문에 어떤 기업이
들어오시던 회사가 들어오시던간에 제가
홍보를 다 해 드릴 거예요 그래서
그건 다 홍보 무료니까 20만 이고요
다면 50만 팔로가 있기 때문에 이런
부동산 분야에 또 홍보가 필요하신
분들은 제가 또 이렇게 노출시킬 수
있도록 계속 제공할테니까 임대로도 좀
많이 관심가 주으면 좋겠습니다 아직
공사가 좀 마무리가 안 돼서 좀
미흡한 부분이 있었습니다 3월 말
4월 초까지는 완벽하게 마무리가 될
거 같아서 만약에 정말 건물에 관심
있으신
분이
m